bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
handball l'équipe senior féminine de
montigny le bretonneux s'est pris une
claque ce week-end contre le paris
saint-germain dessinée montaigne se sont
inclinés sur le score de 22 à 10 dans
leur gymnase pour résumer a su dans
quelques instants au rugby
montigny-le-bretonneux continue son sans
faute dans le championnat de première
série les hommes coachés par cyrine
dorures sont imposés dans la douleur
contre le stade de reims ce week-end à
l'occasion de la 10e journée
plus de détails dans ce magazine
cyclisme sur piste françois pervis
réintègre l'équipe de france le sportif
vient d'être convoqué pour la prochaine
coupe du monde après avoir passé des
tests pour juger sa condition physique
le pistard le plus rapide du monde sur
le kilomètre avait été écarté de
l'équipe avec grégory baugé et michael
d'almeida près des jo-2016 décevant avec
seulement une médaille de bronze à rio
zuma présence sur les principaux
résultats du week-end
on commence donc par du handball
contre-performance pour montillot
bretenoux à l'occasion de la 10e journée
du championnat de nationale 2 lésigny
monteyne ont perdu sur leur terrain
contre le paris saint-germain
le score est sans appel 22 à 10 le
résumé du match nicolas d'andrea pour
les images montigny le bretonneux
redescend sur terre après trois
victoires consécutives dans le
championnat de nationale 2 désigné
monteyne ont concédé une lourde défaite
sur leur terrain contre le paris saint
germain ce samedi 4 février le score 22
à 10 les secteurs défaillants
l'attaquant seconde période montigny le
bretonneux n'a marqué que quatre buts en
30 minutes de jeu mais on n'a pas les
bonnes attitudes et c'est ce qui fait
qu'on n'a pas de réussite on manque
certainement un peu de confiance aussi
en nous mêmes et du coup on n'y va pas
on s'engage pas et on pêche beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup en attaque
le score le montre c'est presque
ridicule on savait qu'on jouait sur une
grosse défense
mais de là à mettre que des buts c'est
quand même compliqué avec beaucoup
d'échecs ont déjà ce que je regrette le
plus c'est que les consignes ne soit pas
appliquée parce que bon c'est surtout
des échecs par rapport à la gardienne
que l'on a eu
échec dû parce que la prise
d'information sur le duel face à la
gardienne n'est pas fait on a tout mis
en bas alors que je demandais depuis
plus de cinquante minutes de tir en
pleine lucarne parce qu'elle se sera
baissée sur ses appuis
cette défaite est un coup d'arrêt dans
la remontée au classement
montigny-le-bretonneux reste à la 9e
place avec un bilan de 4 victoires et 6
défaites depuis le début du championnat
je pense que c'est trop tôt pour avoir
des regrets il faut qu'on travaille on
n'a pas le temps de s'apitoyer sur ce
qu'on a à faire on sait que c'est une
saison compliquée
vu tout un tas de circonstances
maintenant il faut qu'on avance je veux
qu'on arrive à rester solide ensemble et
c'est ce qui est compliqué quand on a un
petit effectif qui enchaîne les matches
comme ça il faut qu'on arrive à rester
ensemble pour la suite la suite arrive
dès ce samedi 11 février
montigny-le-bretonneux se rendra sur le
terrain de noisy le grand gagnant
victoire impérative pour le parrot
tomber dans une spirale négative hameau
de basket à présent dans le championnat
de nationale 3 trap a été corrigée sur
son parquet par sow ce samedi soir au
gymnase paul maillet les trappistes
outsider sur cette rencontre se sont
inclinés 67 à 50 et reste 6e du
classement à quatre points de la
première place occupée par poissy on
écoute le président du club jacques
michée sur les objectifs de fin de
saison était au micro de camille lambert
c'est d'être le d'être le mieux placé
possible parce que le ce que nous
essayons de d'atteindre c'est en fait la
plus grande stabilité possible des
effectifs de l'équipe de façon à débuter
la saison suivante c'est en prochaine
donc de la manière la plus préparé
possible en termes de style de jeu en
termes de connaissances
interindividuelle etc du ballon de
basket on passe au ballon ovale ont joué
ce week end dans le championnat de
première série à montillot bretons ne
s'est une nouvelle fois illustré en
remportant son sa dixième victoire en
dix matches disputés contre le stade de
reims a mal à un montage a signé à
romain a remis 10 sur 10 pour montigny
le bretonneux l'équipe seniors continue
son sans faute dans le championnat de
première série
leur victime du jour le stade reims
cinquième du classement avant la
rencontre
le rouleau compresseur et n'y monte à 1
réussi à remporter la victoire dans la
douleur 16 à 10 au stade roger couderc
sur un terrain lourd
on est passé pas loin de la
correctionnelle face à une équipe de
reims vaillante et sur un terrain lourd
on a donné des consignes aux joueurs
qu'on pas forcément été respectées et
puis on sait que le rugby ça passe par
part du jeu devant à la base
voilà donc voilà on a les quatre points
donc c'est le principal et ça nous
permet de continuer à travailler
sereinement
on n'a pas réussi à développer vraiment
notre rugby on a à jouer bas pas comme
on aurait dû le faire
et puis du coup bah ça mais ça donne un
match serré avec avec un groupe d'avants
chez eux qui étaient très très solide
très costaud mais qui était plutôt
avantagé sur ce genre de terrain avec
cette victoire montigny le bretonneux
s'offrent un boulevard pour terminer
premier du classement de cette poule une
les il monte un contre et ce point
d'avancé sur le second camp gerville
mais les coaches tente de garder les
joueurs sous pression les joueurs on les
lâche pas et puis on rappelle nos
objectifs nos objectifs qui sont de
finir premiers invaincus et puis
d'accéder à cette demi finale de
championnat de france
sachant que la montée est quasi quasi
fait pour valider le plus vite possible
cette première place les joueurs de
montigny le bretonneux tenteront
d'accrocher stains à leur tableau de
chasse
le match est programmé le 19 février
prochain à 15 heures toujours en rugby
mais cette fois ci en fédérale 3 plaisir
est allé s'imposer sur le terrain de
boulogne billancourt sur le score de 39
à 19 à l'occasion de la 12e journée du
championnat une victoire facile qui leur
permet de conserver la tête du
classement
les plaisirs oies sont toujours premier
avec 52 points à égalité avec ris
orangis
prochain match pour plaisir le 19
février prochain contre mot la seule
équipe qui les a battus cette saison
il y avait également du cyclisme sur
piste ce week-end avec la quatrième
manche de la coupe d'hiver
la compétition organisée par le csm
puteaux était programmé ce samedi après
midi au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 148 pistard
venus de huit comités régionaux et
renault ont fait le déplacement pour
cette épreuve qui a été créé cette année
pour permettre aux pistards d'avoir des
courses de haut niveau pendant la
période hivernale on écoute les premiers
bilans au micro de nicolas grange
et bien pour l'instant c'est un succès
parce que lors des quatre premières
manches nous avons eu entre 130 et 150
participants aujourd'hui la quatrième
manche organisée par le csm puteaux a
réuni cent quarante huit engagés on peut
dire d'ores et déjà que cette première
coupe d'hiver est un succès pour la
piste et pour le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
moi je pense que c'est une belle
compétition qu a remporté un beau succès
tout l'hiver
avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
participants pour beaucoup de coureurs
comme pour moi ça permet de maintenir la
forme ou de revenir en forme pour la
saison de route qui arrive qui débute au
mois de
mois de février on reste dans le monde
du cyclisme ligne montrent un françois
pervis réintègre l'équipe de france le
sportif vient d'être convoqué pour la
prochaine coupe du monde après avoir
passé des tests pour juger sa condition
physique
cette convocation est une demi surprise
le pistard le plus rapide du monde sur
le kilomètre avait été écarté de
l'équipe avec grégory baugé et michael
d'almeida après des jo 2016 décevant
avec seulement une médaille de bronze à
rio selon les instances pervis et ses
coéquipiers avaient tué également un
comportement anti sportif pendant la
compétition en critiquant le staff sous
l'impulsion du mystère à des sports le
sprinter et le dtn vincent jacquet
orange est allé couteau on écoute
justement le dirigeant je vous cache pas
que les les moments qu'on a passés ont
été des moments relationnel très tendu
aujourd'hui on a un projet individualisé
par athlète on a une une porte de sortie
qui est intéressante
bah différentes effectivement regarder
des trois athlètes parce que les trois
n'ont pas les mêmes objectifs et des
trois noms marc n'ont pas les mêmes
besoins les mêmes organisations les
mêmes volonté néanmoins il est important
qu'on trouve une solution
on l'a trouvé une nouvelle réunion
devrait être organisée vendredi prochain
pour réintégrer ou non les pistards
baugé et michael d'almeida toujours
ainsi kiss me levais le drone nationale
ne serait peut-être jamais sorti de
terre sans eux à michel auger président
de saint quentin en yvelines ainsi que
son prédécesseur robert cadalbert et
l'ancien vice président yves macheboeuf
ont bataillé avec la région et l'état
pour créer ce projet pour les remercier
à la fédération française de cyclisme a
décidé de les décorer de la médaille
d'or vendredi dernier dans l'enceinte
sportive
paris jacques de dixmude après ce match
la fédération française a organisé ce
vendredi 3 février une cérémonie au
vélodrome nationale objectif rendre
hommage aux acteurs politiques saint
quentinois qui ont oeuvré pour la
construction de la structure
michel laugier président de saint
quentin en yvelines ainsi que son
prédécesseur robert cadalbert et
l'ancien vice président yves macheboeuf
ont reçu la médaille d'or des mains du
président de la ffc david lappartient
la médaille d'or est une médaille très
symbolique il n'en ai remis que 5 par an
donc ça renforce le
le poids et la valeur de cette médaille
et c'était important que je puisse
honorer parce que c'est quand même moi
qui travaille avec eux recevoir la
médaille d'or de la fédération française
de cyclisme
c'était d'odeurs un honneur qui pour moi
illustrent non investissement que j'ai
pu faire pour l'arrivée de la fédération
la construction du vélodrome c'est une
marque qui me va droit au coeur parce
qu'effectivement pour nous à saint
quentin en yvelines
l'arrivée de la fédération et donc la
construction de vire drôme était
effectivement dix ans de travail pour
réaliser ce projet les discussions ont
été âpres
les premières réunions ont eu lieu au
début des années 2000 malgré l'échec de
la candidature de paris aux jo de 2012
le projet est maintenu et officiellement
lancé en 2009 pour une livraison en
janvier 2014
coût global des travaux 74 millions
d'euros en partenariat public privé
c'est jamais évident de sortir des
équipements publics de ce niveau là en
plus on arrive à aider période commence
est difficile et donc il fallait arriver
à bien montrer que globalement le projet
tel qu'il était ficelé tenait la route
tant sur l'aspect d'une réussite
sportive mais aussi de son équilibre
avec les manifestations qu'on pouvait y
faire mais en même temps prendre la
globalité des besoins que ce soit pour
la fédération mais aussi pour le
territoire
mais la plus belle récompense pour est
arrivé le 13 septembre prochain et clete
désignation de la ville hôte pour les jo
de 2024
si le dossier parisien est retenu le
vélodrome à coeur à cette occasion les
épreuves de cyclisme sur piste et le bmx
les jeux olympiques justement le dossier
final a été transmis à ce vendredi 3
février au seuil aux documents dont
notamment une image concrète du déroulé
de la quinzaine olympique et
paralympique le plan logistique
transport hébergement sécurité
expérience des athlètes et spectateurs
sont détaillées dans le dossier en
parallèle le slogan officiel de la
candidature a été dévoilée et l'étende
l'anglais med for sharing que l'on peut
traduire parvenez à partager un message
projeté sur la tour eiffel en compagnie
de plusieurs sportifs de haut niveau
dont le judoka teddy riner
je vous rappelle que les mines sont
particulièrement représentées dans cette
candidature à parisienne puisque l'on
retrouve quatre sites
le château de versailles pour
l'équitation le vtt à la colline
d'elancourt le golf le golf national
situé à guyancourt et enfin les épreuves
de cyclisme sur piste de bmx
vélodrome nationale on sort maintenant
la grand voile pour parler du vendée
globe laurent golly teint à louis burton
a franchi ce jeudi 2 février au matin à
8h40 16 précise la ligne d'arrivée aux
sables d'olonne et termine donc à la 7e
place sur cette édition
le skipper de bureau vallée a bouclé son
tour du monde en solitaire et sans
escale pour la première fois en 87 jours
21h45 avec une vitesse moyenne de 13
noeuds on écoute la première réaction du
navigateur à son arrivée pas vraiment
mon temps décrassage je m'attendais à ce
qu'on m'avait dit que ça serait très
fort je m'attendais pas débouler à 20
noeuds sur la ligne arrivé avec du vent
comme ça + d'élise sur le moteur donc
toute la rentrée là c'est rock and roll
et surtout c'est de voir autant de monde
autant de monde d'un coup au bout de
trois mois de solitude c'est un vrai de
vrai vrai bonheur en fait l'événement de
ce week-end c'est également le super
bowl la finale du championnat de
football américain qui s'est tenue cette
nuit entre les new england patriots et
les falcons d'atlanta
cette soirée a été suivie par plus de
100 millions d'américains et 500
millions de personnes à travers le monde
pour cet événement les templiers
d'elancourt était également devant leur
télévision dans ce restaurant des
clayes-sous-bois comme on peut le voir
sur ces images ils ont pu bénéficier
également d'un show proposé par les
cheerleaders du club avant le match une
ambiance à l'américaine les plus
courageux sont restés jusqu'au bout de
la nuit pour voir la victoire des new
england 34 à 28 après abrogation c'est
la fin de ce set 8 sport merci d'avoir
suivi très belle soirée sur tv fil 78
[Musique]